Chris Han is a radio host and former
aide to Senator Chuck Schumer and he
joins us tonight so Chris I know you
don't like Trump that's fine but speak
slowly so I can understand and explain
to me why paying off someone who is
extorting you threatening to make public
details of your personal life if she
doesn't get paid
why paying that person is a felony well
first of all we don't know that there
was actual extortion here we know that a
payment was made there was a catch and
kill deal with the National Enquirer
whether or not it was extortion that
hasn't been proven yet nor hasn't even
really been alleged in many there's
nothing say I'm alleging it because it's
obvious you're not gonna pay a hundred
grand or a hundred and fifty or two and
a grand is someone unless there's a
threat to you a new reputation this is
extortion now I don't I don't know why
it's not being prosecuted I don't I
don't know why Trump isn't defending
himself in those grounds I would but it
clearly is extortion well but why is it
a crime let's go pay up someone
sometimes who you had an affair
sometimes people want to tell us they
want to tell a story that he doesn't
want told he says hey just tell it to me
I'll pay for it and that's what if I did
that to you you would call it if I said
look I know a detail about your sex life
Chris Han and I'm gonna tell it on my
show on TV unless you pay me that would
be extortion obviously so this extortion
but leaving that aside why is it a
felony to pay women you've had sexual
relationships with it's not a felony
it's a felony to do a campaign
expenditure and not it and not disclose
it and that's what was that a campaign
exists seems to have been a campaign he
made this during the campaign for the
purposes of the campaign there are tape
recordings of him discussing this with
Michael Cohen
and that was for the purposes of the kid
we just hold on wait hold on I'm
confused no it's not a small thing it's
the thing this is the crime that the New
York time told us on Saturday federal
prosecutors are alleging the president
committed a felony and Michael Cohen
pled guilty to a species of this so I
just want to get to the bottom of it why
is that a campaign contributions you pay
off a former girlfriend I'm honestly
confused
you're a campaign guy tell me there
there look there's also an allegation
that he may have violated the Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act when he was doing
his deal with their allegations
there's a lot there's a lot more to this
than just pay well how about one a
legate of one allegation
one allegation at a time so federal
prosecutors is not just something that
dumb people on TV are talking about
though they are this is something that
prosecutors in New York State are saying
they have apparently evidence to indict
over so tell me why because a lot of
people in Washington pay off their
girlfriends including lots of people in
Congress a lot of people in Congress
ugly I'd even get some Democrats just
thrown that out there so tell me why
that's a campaign contribution to pay
off your girlfriend well first of all I
think that fund that Congress was using
to pay people off for her ass needs to
be disclosed and the members who were
involved with those disclosure decisions
need to be removed oh I'm sure that'll
happen right away that'll happen right
away I'm sure I'm as NBC what are you on
that point this is central question why
is it and for all of us well why is that
a campaign issue the money didn't come
from the campaign it didn't go to the
campaign it was a threat to his
reputation and its livelihood as all
extortion is right so why is that
campaign contributions lack letter law
there's black letter law here okay then
what is the finance law is pretty clear
about what you can and cannot do with
funds and these funds were not
necessarily good from Trump's own
pockets there was all sorts of schemes
put together by the president and
Michael Cohen to move this money around
so it wasn't traced back to the
president itself to raise reflects you
know it may be I mean we've never had a
president like Trump in a million
different ways and I'm not defending you
ever have I'm not defending his personal
life I'm merely saying this is now being
described as a felony as a crime for
which the president could be removed so
now's the time but we need to be very
specific about what the crime is because
you're you've stopped all business of
government so we can respond this so
let's respond right now tell me how and
where in campaign finance law it says
you're not allowed to use your money
there's no allegation this was campaign
money your money to pay off from a
girlfriend there isn't and that's this
made us not it's a lot the allegation
here is not the allegation here is not
that it's just his money
there's allegation that he moved money
around through various schemes but no
but not not from the kidney to do that
to payments that is your money pain in
nature that is a violation of campaign
in violation of campaign funds know just
what you speak and I'll let you speak
slowly so our audience can understand
wearing campaign finance law does it say
the ticking money that's not from your
political campaign to respond to an
extortion attempt or pay off your
girlfriend or pay the gardener or pay
anybody why is that a felony where does
it say that can you talk to him pay in
finance law well I'm not gonna quote
this section in verse I don't know it
off the top of my head even more when
the campaign finance campaign finance
law clearly states that any money spent
for campaign purposes specifically by
people other than the candidate must be
disclosed but why does that I can't like
right here that hold on hold on hold on
the president and Michael Cohen clearly
set up a scheme so that other people
could pay these women off on behalf of
Donald Trump while he was running for
president because these allegations
would sink his campaign and his
reputation but maybe maybe under no
actually because anybody faced I'm not
you know I don't know a single man who
faces that allegation who he thought he
could squelch it wouldn't pay the person
off because it doesn't calculate and to
your reputation whether you're running
for anything or not and so that's it's
so clearly not a campaign violation that
I wonder if we want to set this
precedent do you want to live in a world
where people paying off extortion
attempts are now campaign finance felons
I mean this is you know this this is
strikingly similar to what happened to
John Edwards and what happens yes
iteration and what happened there's
another populace they kick out with this
BS campaign finance nonsense
exactly what happened to campaign
finance law it's more than campaign
finance law it is the Foreign Corrupt
Practices Act let's only separate a
problem look if he violated yeah and
also in this case
it's part of this all right Chris on
thank you thank you see